Well
hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with their brief information for today, Tuesday
, February 23, after almost 50 years, the
Greyhound bus terminal located
in downtown Las Vegas closes its
doors, it will move to near the airport
on Sanz, it closed in  December La Plaza
announced that it would not renew the contract
as this property plans to offer new
shops, restaurants and more
entertainment
options.  they will have to verify the
corresponding buses for their children in addition
to that they will have an assigned seat
both children and drivers
will have to wear masks while
the buses will only operate with a
limit of 50 percent capacity
due to the virus
if you are over 65 and live  in
biggest rules you can sign up to receive
the virus vaccine the city
announced that you will be given the pr  first dose
to a certain number of people
starting tomorrow visit
acz at vi dotcom for more
information and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have a
sunny sky with a maximum of 73 degrees for
today however some winds are expected
for the  Wednesday and Thursday in the
valley have a nice day I am
sal y jaramillo and this was their brief
informative about them neil in Spanish
[Music]